All righty then.
It is time for Drew's News.
You're the produce section
that we're refreshing with that good news mist.
And say hello to my trusty co-pilot, Rossy Ross Matthews.
Hi, everybody.
Hi, Drew.
I love you.
Okay, Ross, this first story is tailor made for you,
and when I found out some details about it, my jaw dropped.
Get ready for this.
Oh, I'm ready.
Okay, it's the Queen's Platinum Jubilee year,
and that 70 years on the throne.
I feel like we've been hearing about this,
but these new details are going to blow your mind.
All right, Digital Spy reports that for the first time ever,
the Jubilee will be televised
and it's going to be hosted by an epic duo.
You guys, I can't even believe
I'm about to say these two names.
Okay, are you ready for the two names?
Yes.
Tom Cruise and Helen Mirren.
What?
Where did they...
What the?
Yes.
It's going to be a huge star studded affair
complete with military and equestrian displays,
a 75 piece orchestra, a huge theater,
done in four acts traveling through royal history
starting with the reign of the Queen Elizabeth,
the first played of course by Helen Mirren.
This is a play that's gonna be put on.
This is insane.
This is what we call a dream come true.
All right, break out the fine China,
get me some tea and crumpets, and do not bother me
until the Jubilee is over
'cause I'm watching every single second.
(audience applauds)
And from now on every party I have,
I'm gonna call it a Jubilee because it's so fun to say.
I'm calling my wedding a Jubilee.
Good. Let's do it.
(audience applauding)
Right. That's exciting.
Well, if you think that's exciting, check this out.
It's the cover, the new cover of Better Homes & Gardens,
and wowza, it's Harry Styles on the cover.
Look at this.
The June issue is hot off the presses today
and available at bhg.com and on news stands everywhere.
The interview covers Harry's love
of taking a dip in a cold pool.
Everybody just picture that for a second.
He says he swims outdoors every single day,
and of course his brand new album,
Harry's House, is out next week.
(audience applauds)
I'm so excited.
He says it explores his definition of what home is.
He said, "It's not a feeling you get from an actual place.
It's internal, it's a head space and sense of wellbeing
that you take everywhere you go.
You can bring home with you."
Okay, here is my take on this.
Okay. Go.
Because I am really freaking out.
I think I love magazines, okay?
Like I make a magazine, okay?
That's how serious I am.
I love magazines, I subscribe to them, I live for them.
Yes you do.
Every magazine matters to me.
I care so much about magazines.
And when I saw this, I just thought
I really don't understand how this happened.
I wanna do some deep dive investigative reporting.
I wanna know who called who?
Did Harry's publicist call Better Homes & Gardens?
Did Better Homes & Gardens reach out to him?
Why does Harry just do whatever he wants to do
and make everything cool?
He's gonna change that magazine.
Like, magazines watch out.
Better Homes & Gardens is coming for you.
I just can't wait 'til he's on the cover
of Popular Mechanics.
I am really looking forward to that.
(audience applauds)
Doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make any sense.
But I'm here for it,
Better Homes & Gardens.
It's just so incredible.
Harry Styles, you keep doing you
and just breaking all the rules,
and you're gonna improve the enterprises
of all the things you touch.
I love Harry Styles.
All right, well, speaking of another periodical
that I absolutely love, Travel + Leisure reports
that there's a swanky new way to get to space.
Check this out.
Spaceship Neptune, this luxury flight,
can take you to the edge of the universe
for a breathtaking 360 degree view of our precious planet.
On the outside, it looks like a balloon
the size of a football field,
but on the inside it's really dope.
Straight up dope, dope in the sky.
Plush seats, mood lighting.
Flights are sold out for 2024,
but you can reserve your spot in 2025 for,
and here's where I get a little grumpy, $125,000 a pop.
Wow.
Enjoy that view.
Yeah.
God, why does this tick me off so much?
Well, 'cause it's a lot of money.
I mean, I wanted to go until I heard that.
Now I'm waiting for a groupon.
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
Imagine $125,000.
Totally, I'm also just like,
we need $125,000 here on Earth.
Earth first.
Yeah, Earth first.
(audience applauds)
But if they can figure out a way
to lower the price a little bit,
I would go on this in a heartbeat
and I actually think we should do it together
and do Drew's News in space.
Are you in?
If we can figure it out?
(audience applauds)
If we can get a groupon
or we can get them to like donate
our money for our seats to a charity, I'm in.
I'm in too.
Okay. Done.
Watch out.
(upbeat bright music)